Oh how's it gonna press up so dark
welcome to my my blog this is going to
be the best vlog you've ever seen so
we're going to New York for Fashion Week
yay
I love fashion I'm all about looking
outfit oh it's gonna be good thank you
you gotta miss you buddy I'm gonna miss
you so much what did you say I'm gonna
miss you so much again that's right you
you dirty [ __ ] who's gonna give me dog
food you're so black I can't even see
you that's right that's right
I'll see you in a bed woof hi boots
I just want to say that I look
Wow
and then you get sleepy select this
hotel because of the view I want to show
you them yes because of this second year
good night
mmm Oh
cuddle kid thinks much good morning
don't worry about it I always sleep with
my with my clothes on welcome to New
York it's love's [ __ ] let's say let's
take a look at the view that we ordered
Wow
so yeah we're gonna explore and you
press are coming with me
let's free New York yeah you can hear
from the honking we're going to sender
Park straight ahead to go to the
planetarium it's so cold I don't even
want can you see the fool
you probably hear me why is it so cold I
should have been complaining of Swedish
pathology sorry
look at all those chickens go Pete am
awesome Thank You Provost okay just
kidding
all of ocean life it's on the first
floor you are on first floor
hi it's this place
yeah your she'll feel it yeah I bet you
get this all the time so yeah now that
up there can we go yeah let's say I like
there's a mighty yeah Mexican I can go
for the mix kick
yeah
gonna go ahead
look at that you can hear it oh my God
look how much [ __ ] Wally are you
gonna eat that we're here again Lincoln
Center is pretty cool I like it I'm
ready you look at me so weird when I
vlog ready to flip just kill the runway
let's do it is
Oh
it was pretty cool I like I like it even
though even I feel like even if I like
it then it's pretty cool so we're going
back hopefully we can get a cab we are
going to the airport I mean we are at
the airport hey say hi to YouTube oh we
have fun where are you guys going Boston
we're actually moving to Florida finally
so we're out
please ensure your carry-on items and
tray tables are stove your seat back is
fully upright and your seat belt is
securely fastened and it back in UK
hey hey hey I missed you miss me I miss
me I miss you and where did it go
where did they go can you let me go now
ah oh are you okay oh my isn't feeling
well she's old and she gets a lot of
stomachaches oh she's like save me save
me P we're back it feels great to be
back I had a great trip my expectations
were loved but I enjoyed I enjoyed
myself I thought I thought it was fun
going away you appreciate what you have
at home as well a bit more thank you
both for joining me in this trip to New
York I hope you enjoyed this vlog don't
forget to leave a thumbs up if you want
more vlogs and I will see you bros in
the next one here's the brofist you
think I wasn't gonna do it all